welcome to Mogul money
and that wraps up our first segment of
Moga money both trivia Boards out of the
way and we have to say goodbye
I'll see you later all right so sorry
for your loss but we will have Hassan
and codyko competing in quick money
just quick break for five thousand
dollars I'm not leaving okay you got it
I'm not [ __ ] leave carrying two
points
Cody congratulations you are the winner
of multiple money episode two you're
gonna walk home with five thousand
dollars
yeah that's a nice one it's a heated
seat
it's in your badge in your mic pack
there's three Double A's in your mic
pack it'll be good either way thank you
all so much for watching please tune in
next month September 7th for our next
episode and tweet out hashtag mobile
money who you want to see
um thank you so much for coming on guys
I really appreciate it devastating I'm
buying some Gucci bags dude wait so I
have to bring up Mogul money because
uh after we did that I got so many
people calling me stupid
yeah yeah and there's the stupid
Chatters doing that so that's like
double Burn yeah it's like I'm getting
called stupid by stupid people uh I felt
like the Kazakhstan thing I'll never
live that down dude would you do again
yeah I don't it was it was like the it
was like the question to answer to save
it all and I was gonna say Kazakhstan
and you literally just you hit me by
like a millisecond so I was fast you
were oh so I just like won the game yeah
okay that was your Duke degree at work
right there that's what all four years
were for for that moment right there all
the geography classes I took at Duke
yeah did you get paid out for that no
no I didn't I actually wanted to ask you
that I was like was it a joke that I was
supposed to win money because I never
got no you know what cash at me right
now [ __ ]
this is like yeah dude yeah
it's like 13 bucks I think
there's a five in there he actually
dollars you don't realize this degree
counts yeah yeah it's got to be down to
the penny you don't realize this that's
the money he took out of your pockets
after he knocked you out
by the way speaking of which
it's gonna be really awkward if Ludwig
doesn't answer now
I'm live what's up
I have a feeling it's not gonna answer
yeah
y'all sleep in the same bed so
three two
one oh look at the buzzer homie from
half court holy [ __ ] hey you owe Cody
money
run me my bread five thousand dollars
[Music]
well I can't leave here until you pay
him fine you can't leave there yeah yeah
it's a hostage situation yeah she's in
space dude and our executive producers
flirting with her he keeps calling her
cutie
and he's married
[Laughter]
this all seems bad
yeah so give us the money yeah oh you
never see your cutie again
all right the 5000 comment it's coming
I'll get it all right dude all right let
me know if you need my venmo or what a
PayPal whatever that's weird the call
just disconnected
I'll put the location for the money on a
cut.com video
[Laughter]
let's just reiterate that he said I'll
put the location for the money on a
cut.com
it was a bad joke so not a good joke I
was just calling to tell you hi and I
miss you
if you did that with Hassan before yeah
nothing see you later wait speaking of
paint me
oh I gotta update you holy [ __ ] is this
a brand Ludwig oh never mind hit me up
on Discord
said send me your W-9 I'm gonna get you
paid he's [ __ ] paying me wow oh [ __ ]
five grand that doesn't look anything
and so what for what because I won his
uh his like game show Mogul money oh
[ __ ] he never paid you he never paid me
damn and I kept he must be good news
about it finally he's paying me yeah
he's definitely he's new to it what is
it and I'm gonna give it to a random
person in Croatia
fiance uh in my house
one random fiance that lives with me I'm
gonna give it to her wow yeah so
generous of you I know I mean that's
just yeah for her to buy philanthropy
for you for her to buy you potentially a
five thousand dollar watch or something
like that as a gift